I mean here by Congressman John Lewis
among those on hand for that event how
many people were here for the March well
the National Park Service said 250,000
but I do believe it was the greatest
undercurrent of all time when I look at
Steele photographs when I look at video
I think it was many more in 250,000 when
you Stewart that day and look down the
mall it was a sea of humanity and you
were there let's show our audience this
photograph of a 23 year old speaker
you're the only sole survivor of the
leading speakers from the march on
Washington what was it like for you when
you stepped up to that podium a fellow
Randolph who was the chair of the march
on Washington introduced me by saying 9%
to you young John Lewis the national
chair of the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee I walk straight
to the podium I look to my right and saw
a group of young people young activists
from the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee the organization that I had at
at the time then I looked at the left I
saw another group of young people up in
the trees trying to get a better view of
the podium and I look straight ahead and
I just said to myself I must go for it
and it was just unreal unbelievable
we thought maybe 50 or 60,000 people
will show up but it was many many more
your words quote we will march through
the south through the streets of Jackson
through the streets of Danville through
the streets of Cambridge through the
streets of Birmingham but we will march
with the spirit of love and with the
spirit of dignity that we have shown
here today we must say wake up America
wake up what were you saying what I was
trying to say that we have come to
Washington demanding change we came to
Washington on that day to petition our
government i president members of
Congress and I wanted to try to display
the sense of urgency and as a matter of
fact early in the speech I said we do
not
when our freedom gradually but we wanted
everyone and I was saying in the fact
that there would be no turning back that
we would not give up that we would not
give in that we would not give out that
we were prepared not just to come to
Washington but also march in these other
places all across America from your book
walking with a win you indicate that
luther king was not the originator of
the march on washington idea who was the
originator of the march on washington
was a man by the name of a fuller
Randolph was of like labor leader he was
considered the Dean of like leadership a
fella Randolph has threatened a march
during the Roosevelt administration let
me just stop you there there's a
photograph of him in the book is this in
standing next to President Kennedy that
is mr. Randolph you know much earlier
yes during the summer 1963 we had a
meeting with President Kennedy I believe
that meeting took place in the White
House own I will never forget it on June
22nd 1963 and it was in at meeting but
mr. Randolph and dr. King and other
leaders to six of us mr. Randolph spoke
up and said mr. president in his
baritone voice we're gonna have a march
on Washington and you could tell by the
body language of President Kennedy he
didn't like what he heard you start
moving in his chair and he said mr.
Randolph if you bring all these people
to Washington
they'll be violent there will be chaos
disorder and we would never be able to
get a civil rights bill through the
Congress
mr. Randolph responded best there mr.
president this would be an orderly
peaceful nonviolent protest we left that
meeting with President Kennedy came out
on the lawn of the White House announced
to the media that we were planning a
march on Washington and in the book you
say mr. Randolph had a meeting 20 years
previously with another president that
ended in no march whatsoever can you
explain well mr. Randolph was able to
negotiate an understanding with mr.
Roosevelt and with others and he did not
have the March but he always looked
forward he always had this idea somehow
in some way we should be prepared
to use nonviolent protests he negotiated
at Roosevelt rumah and with others our
guest Congressman John Lewis Democrat
from Georgia our phone lines are open at
two zero two five eight five thirty
eight eighty four Republicans into zero
two five eight five thirty eight eighty
one for Democrats aligned for
independence and for those of you
watching outside the United States how
did the media portray this event back in
1963 in nineteen sixty three most of the
media said in effect seven hundred
thousand people together in Washington
for March for civil rights and that it
was orderly and peaceful and it
highlighted the speech of dr. Mardis
again jr. and rightly so
what did you think of this speech by dr.
King I had heard adopted King's become
so many occasion all across the south
but in other places in the north and it
was a wonderful speech in my estimation
he started off slow deliberate and he
got to the point southern middle of the
speech he said I have a dream today a
dream that is deeply rooted in American
dream and he was talking to the people
and the people was talking back to him I
think it was a magnificent speech and it
will go down as one of the most powerful
and one of the most influential speeches
of all times but in your book you said
in your opinion it was not his greatest
speech why well I heard him I've heard
him speak in some small churches in
rural communities I heard him in New
York and Philadelphia Pittsburgh and
Detroit but the speech that I thought
was his greatest speech or his best
Beach the one where he's just just spoke
from its gut and his heart and he felt
so strongly about it the speech he gave
on April the 4th 1967 one year to the
date before was assassinated when you
spoke out against the war in Vietnam me
point to this photograph from your book
and ask you
about the big six who were they this
photograph from July 1963 that
photograph was taken on July 2nd 1963 in
New York City that's what we issued the
call for the march on Washington the big
sticks a fella Randolph labor leader Roy
Wilkins of the NAACP James form a core
with the young other Urban League Martin
Luther King was head of a Southern
Christian Leadership Conference and
young John Lewis with a little bit more
hair back I had hey and I was a few
pounds lighter Herndon Virginia for
congressman Lewis good morning
hello go ahead caller hi good morning
congressman Lewis good morning
I just wanted to see if whether or not
I'm trying I'm not like I'm forwarding a
tape of the march on Washington I saw on
PBS that they had an organizer they
organized the actual March and I can't
remember his name because I never heard
of him until I saw it on PBS and you
might get help me but he was standing
next to mr. farmer and he was standing
next to Martin and according to history
he was the original organizer he had
gotten arrested for some type of sexual
act back in the day so when nobody
wanted to give him credit for it and I
just wondered if you knew his name the
person that you're speaking are is by
dressed in who was the deputy director
of the march on Washington he was an
aide and close confidant of a fellow
Randolph by Rustin was brilliant
unbelievable as an organizer he believed
in the philosophy and a discipline a
nonviolent with ID Rustin involvement we
would have not been able to pull the
march on Washington a LOF fact this is a
photograph from your book and I also
want to show our audience if they want
to pick it up from today's arts and
ideas from the 8th section of the New
York Times is a photograph of mr. Rustin
at the moment of triumph as it's being
called in August 1963 at the march on
Washington next call is Westport
Connecticut good morning good morning I
wonder why this is considered a partisan
issue this was an important historic
event important to all Americans and yet
the lines are divided Republican and
Democratic well the march on Washington
was not a partisan issue it was not
Democrats the Republican as President
Kennedy said in June of 1963 the issue
erase the issues of arrives is a moral
issue why was there any discussion for
President Kennedy to come to the March
because he was at the White House on
that August day there was not any
discussion on the possibility or any
consideration or inviting the President
to come President Kennedy has some real
reservations about the march on
Washington but to know after the march
on Washington after the march on
Washington he invited us all down to the
White House and he had a wonderful
meeting with him he stood in a door of
the Oval Office and greeted each one of
us and he said you did a good job I'm so
proud of you
it was almost like a father being very
proud of his children next call is from
st. Louis from a caller who was here 40
years ago good morning hello I was there
I lived in New York at the time and it's
something that I will never ever forget
I'm 72 I talk to my grandchildren about
him I tell him about the March and about
me going back and then how important it
is to keep up the fight let me ask you
about how you heard about the March and
how you made it down to Washington from
New York at the time and you know it's
really strange in New York it was just
all over my husband worked at a factory
and they were the union was paying for
their bus and then he was going and then
we started listening to I started
listening to different people I went
with my church and it cost us $4 from
what New York to Washington we stood up
all day long after we got off that bus
that morning we left New York at 12
o'clock we got in our Washington it and
we stood
day long do you know that I still have
never been more elated and I was not
tired like you would think that you
would be you forgot the most wonderful
things that has ever happened and yes I
agree there were many more people than
what the statistics will report thank
you so much mr. mr. Lewis thank you for
the call we appreciate it what was it
like here on that day will you remember
about the conditions the weather and the
crowds on that day it was very very hot
it's very hot hot August day in
Washington but the crowd as the caller
suggested was calm people Stewart and
for the most part the crowd was so well
dressed it was unreal
especially those people coming from the
heart of the south for many of the
african-americans coming from the heart
of the deep south it was their first
trip to Washington so they felt they had
to dress up you saw men that jackets
women with wearing hats
it was wonderful but one of the most
amazing thing that I saw when you looked
out over the crime you saw hundreds and
thousands of people white and blind
taking off their shoes putting their
feet in the no reflection pool to try to
to cool off
what was the Student Nonviolent
Coalition the student hour needing
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee was an
organization that emerged during the
spring of 1960 to coordinate the sit-ins
the nonviolent protests on a part of a
college students at all of the college
campus and we got sympathy of support
from student groups in the north it was
based in Atlanta I became the third
chair in June 1963 and 14 days seven
days rather as I became to chair the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee I was invited to the White
House to meet with President Kennedy
along with the other fire of leaders
then three years after that March
Stokely Carmichael had you removed as
the chairman of that committee
why called Snicket cause snake is what's
called a snake a short I guess for the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee a depressed dog was snake and
there was a feeling on the part of
Stokely Carmichael and some other that I
was too close to monitor cane jr. that I
was too committed to the philosophy and
discipline and environment they didn't
think I was militant enough or radical
enough they wanted me to take all
morning to King jr. take on Lyndon
Johnson its president I disagree with
President Johnson on anything but I was
not going to get in the name-calling
process a thing with Lyndon Johnson uh
with dr. King dr. King was my friend I
was on his board the board of SCLC was
my leader he was my hero and I stepped
it the role as a participant and in my
staff has some great leader I saw myself
as one of the participants in this
liberation movement another look at the
photograph how long was your speech in
August 1963 do you remember no I don't
really recall the lens but I think must
speak to only about maybe about seven
minutes I think we all were supposed to
limit our speeches to within seven
minutes were you nervous no I was not
nervous when I got up I had what I call
an executive session with myself it's uh
you shouldn't talk back to yourself but
I just said this is that I'm going for
it and that's what I did you know there
have been some controversy about my
speech because I use a phrase in the
speech first that we're now involved in
a serious revolution the black masters
are restless and some people wanted me
to delete the word revolution and a
Phillip Randolph came to my rescue
I said there's nothing wrong with the
word revolution I used it myself some
time and then near the end of the speech
they wanted me to change and we did
change it I said if we do not see
meaningful progress here today the day
may come when we were not confined on
marching on Washington but we may be
forced to march to dissolve the way
Sherman did none
so we deleted that portion for this
speech next call is from Hutchinson
Kansas good morning hello mr. Lewis
good morning I just wanted to tell you
that even though I am a conservative
Republic and I have great respect for
you well I appreciate that
yes and I have sort of followed you you
know through the marches and everything
I'm 75 years old and I think that you
should probably go down in history as
one of the greats and looking forward to
Oh monuments or something in your honor
somewhere and God bless you keep up the
good work
god bless you I don't want to see any
monuments anything like that built for
me I just tried to get involved and do
my best to make things better not for
african-americans alone but for all
people I've said over and over again
that we want people with one family with
one house we all live in the same house
and we must work together to build what
I like to call the Beloved Community a
truly interracial democracy in America
good morning to Greensboro North
Carolina good morning and thank God for
longevity imagine I was there at March
that day standing under the trees on the
right hand side of the podium and I just
want to ask you this I want the pledge
the dedication of the plaque yesterday
and I was brought to tears at the time
that dr. Michael and they played the
excerpts from the speech and at the time
that you see after the speech catch so
really in depth and series and when most
of the people who have become
wine and of course I was trying then and
40 years later watching and hearing I
cried again
I was taken all the way back for years
to that very time at the lodge I wonder
did that did you have that you sang
psycho feeling well I must tell you it
was very moving yesterday and each time
I hear the speech but to be there
yesterday I was brought to tears you
know I been here in Washington for a few
years and I go to the Lincoln Memorial
from time to time to the Jefferson to
the Washington Monument there Roosevelt
in your city's inscription the sands of
our great leaders and to stand there
yesterday to listen to the words the
more Luther King jr. 40 years later and
to see car there in granite I have a
dream mourned if the King jr. a march on
Washington August 28 1963 it was just
too much for me and I just wish that dr.
King and others who started on this
march on this journey was still around
to see the distance we've come to
progress with me our next call Silver
Spring Maryland good morning brother
John Lewis I look at you and I see
Martin god bless you for the beautiful
things you do for black people and for
our nation thank you
but thank you I thank you for calling we
must continue to work for the day when
we will no longer have to march and work
for all America and for all people for
Humanity Houston Texas you're next
yeah where of all the Liberals gone I
see Jesus Christ crucified John Kennedy
killed Martin Luther King killed Robert
Kennedy killed John Lennon killed that's
where they went
thank you
among the photographs in your book and
among the descriptions that you write
about in detail your work with Robert F
Kennedy and being at the Ambassador
Hotel in June 1968 well a Robert Kennedy
became someone that our my respected and
loved I got to know him very well during
the height of the civil rights movement
as the matter of fact I was with Robert
Kennedy the night that we heard that dr.
King had been assassinated April 4th
1968 I was campaigning for him and then
after dr. King's funeral I went to
California to continue to campaign for
Robert Kennedy and I was in his hotel
room before he went down to give his
victory statement and he sort of jumped
with me he said John you let me down the
de Mol mexican-american turned out to
vote dear Negros he was solid joking and
he suggested that I remain there with
others until he came back and he made
its Victor statement and a few minutes
later it flashed on television that
Robert Kennedy had been shot that was
very sad and I saw her said what are we
going to do I cried a little and I just
wanted to get out of California leave LA
and I got on a flight the next day and
flew to Atlanta and Robert Kennedy
passed and his family got in touch and
suggested that I come to New York for
the funeral romance and staying at under
guard the night before the funeral and
attended the funeral and after the
funeral boarded the funeral train and
came to Washington to bury our
opportunity what do you remember from
that speech on that April day of 1968
that Robert Kennedy delivered in
Indianapolis it was you know he did it
it was impromptu he spoke from his soul
he spoke from his heart he had a very
soothing effect
I think on that audience you know many
people around the nation
he called on American and African
Americans in particular not to resort to
violence
he said that dr. King was a man of peace
a man of non-violence next call is from
Port Arthur Texas good morning go ahead
caller
yes congressman Lewis god bless you
Jackie Savoy from Port Arthur Texas I
just wanted to say because so many of
our young people and a lot of us if
we're a certain age weren't a part of
the movement and and you know relate
back to well I really didn't know that
this happened and we don't teach the
history it's just so good to see that
you're there and you're still the lone
person living and you were such a hero
in all of this that we can let you to
see that you can go from youth to
leadership sometimes it may seem like a
facade to our children that believe in
the values and the policies that you
support so I just hope God continues to
bless you too that you continue to tell
this story so that we do have this
living history in you and that youth
that are that are 23 year olds and we
have brilliant 23 year olds of all
colors and party backgrounds that
believe that we should all live in this
country and to be judged not by the
color of our skin but the content of our
character and and congressman it's a lot
of places a member of Congress could be
doing their break they could be at home
or in Crawford Texas like the president
but you're there being a living history
to our country and god bless you and god
bless this country and God bless this
40th commemorative March but well thank
you very much for calling
you know I first heard of Martha King
jr. when I was 15 years old in the tenth
grade or heard his voice on the radio
I heard his message and he inspired me
and three years later I met dr. King
and it changed my life I had only thing
I was set to a young American to all
young people study the history of the
movement and find a way to face that
history and we all can do something to
make our country a better place you know
we just didn't go out one day instead we
gonna sit in are we going to March I'll
be going to pick it we organized we
studied we studied the philosophy and
the discipline of non-violence we didn't
have a website we didn't have a cellular
telephone we didn't have a fax machine
we believed in the Constitution we
believed in ourselves and we had faith
in our fellow man that we could do
something and we did it nearly two years
after the march on Washington and before
the civil rights bill was signed Life
magazine had a photograph of you and dr.
King on the cover it's called it was
called civil rights faceoff at Selma the
savage season begins can you explain
this is Selma Alabama in 1965 and a
young man stand beside me is Jose
William who was working for dr. King in
Selma Alabama like so much of the South
in the early 60 people of color could
not register to vote had to pass the
so-called literacy test pay a poll-tax
on one occasion it was a black man who
had a PhD degree and he flunked a
so-called literacy test on another
occasion a man was asked to give the
number of bubbles in a ball so people
have been beaten some people shot and
some people kill so in Selma people
stood in unmovable lines for years but
to try to pass the literacy test to
become registered voters my own mother
my own father long grandfather could not
register to vote I could not register to
vote in my native state of Alabama
so we decided after a young person had
been shot and killed about 35 miles from
Selma Alabama in 1965
to march from Selma to Montgomery to
petition governor Wallace and we set out
to March an orderly peaceful nonviolent
fashion and we were met by a group of
Alabama state troopers what we were
beaten and that march from Selma to
Montgomery created the climate
environment where the President of the
United States Lyndon Johnson came before
jurisdiction of the Congress and
introduced the Voting Rights Act of 1965
the Congress debated that I debated the
bill the Congress passed and President
Johnson signed it into law
on August 6 1965 Bowie Maryland for
representative John Lewis of Georgia
good morning yes hi good morning Steve
good morning representative Lewis good
morning I'm calling from Bowie I'm not
in your district of course I mean
Allen's District congressional district
but what I wanted to say to you this
morning is I really do appreciate and
admire what you and and the
Congressional Black Caucus is doing on
Capitol Hill I respect this history so
very much 20 years ago I was involved
with an organization that helped plan
the 20th anniversary mobilization March
or the march on Washington so I really
do respect our history but I also
realized that we have a future
and I look at you and I look at look at
other members of the Congressional Black
Caucus and I look at what's going on in
this whole world
and I realize and in our country that
our fight is just not over so I
appreciate what you're doing and I want
you to know that in case you don't hear
it enough from some regular people who
work everyday who pay attention to
what's going on in the world thank you
thank you for the call thank you we'll
move on to Atlanta Georgia good morning
to you hello this is Caroline Godfrey
and I live in John Lewis's district I am
registered as a Republican but I vote
for John Lewis that every election
then he's done a wonderful job for our
district the most important thing that I
appreciate from him is as he's gone on
to Washington he is not forgot the
people he served he's very much involved
in our district I had talked to his
office on number of occasions about
problems and always got a response and
letters and it's just so nice to see
someone that goes to Washington this
field stays in touch with the people
that that he is serving and he does a
wonderful job here and I'm proud to live
in his district our fight now is not so
much
I don't think against blacks and whites
as it is against the working class and
the wealthier class and the broader
that's coming from that it's getting to
be a broader distance between the two
and I appreciate his efforts there well
thank you so much for calling when you
come to Washington sometime please come
by and visit with me I agree with you so
much and I really appreciate you your
calling you know when dr. King was
assassinated April 4th 1968 he was
trying to organize all segments of the
society that had been left hadn't left
behind the last time I saw dr. King
alive was in Atlanta we have brought
together low-income whites and blacks
and Hispanics Asian American and Native
American and I agree the struggle is the
people to that the bottom that they're
hurting we need to do something about
health care we need to protect and say
the environment that environment is it's
not protecting the environment it's not
a issue a racist not ye2 blank all of us
should know what is in the food we eat
what is in the water we we drink and
what is in the air we breathe let me go
back to a philip Randolph who from this
photograph in the center standing next
to dr. King and as you say in your book
was the originator of the idea of the
march on Washington but did these six
individuals yourself included have a
different view on what the goal of the
march should be
as a group this is unreal
this is really unreal as a group we we
agreed that was a sense of it was a
consensus there was unbelievable
solidarity dr. King had emerged as a
symbol as the undisputed leader because
he had the ability and the capacity to
bring more people together but it was a
filler Randolph that had the capacity to
hold us together in some of those
meeting mr. Randolph was there friend
somebody who sort of went off he would
say things like if she can I say
something good about somebody don't say
anything and I said in recent days that
if a filler end off had been born in
another country on another continent
maybe of another race he probably would
have been king Prime Minister a
president this was a unbelievable human
being and he was just a good decent man
and he wanted to help all people
especially working people blacks white
Hispanic Asian American Native American
next call is from Minneapolis good
morning good morning you know I I knew
two people who were tomorrow I was at
the marks on the left side under the
trees but I had two comets roommates to
college acquaintances John Baba and AD
King
how about if you would comment I was
also in Montgomery doing the doing the
problems in Montgomery 1956 I feel would
appreciate if you comment on these two
people and their role in the march on
Washington ad King and John Barban John
Barban speech right of a king would you
comment on those two you'd never hear
their names I like to know something
about their role well thank you very
much ad King was dr. King's brother I
mean John barber I remember both John
barber and ad King very well they played
supporting roles dr. Kane during this
lifetime will always speak about the
ground crew those
who make things happen those who get out
there without the names a pin and a
paper or faces on television and just
during the hard nitty-gritty work and
hundreds and thousands of our citizens
black and white did the dirty nitty
gritty work making signs getting water
fooled bailing people out of jail and we
all are very grateful and thankful for
the ground crew page 226 of your book
their stories the media portrayed the
event as a big picnic a hootenanny
combined with the spirit of a revival
prayer meeting too many commentators and
reporters softened and trivialized the
hard edges in pain and suffering that
brought about this day in the first
place I think many members of the media
did not connect the March with the
climate with the environment that
existed in America just before the march
on Washington ball Connor had used dogs
and fire hoses Bull Connor was the
police commissioner in Birmingham
Alabama
he used dogs and fire hoses against
peaceful nonviolent protesters a NACP
leader mega Everest have been
assassinated in Mississippi hundreds and
thousands of people have been arrested
jail some beacon and some kill so the
March just in come out of some day we
decided to March I think when we arrived
in Washington with the speeches with the
music people saw it as so orderly so
peaceful some people expected chaos
disorder expected violence but it was
one of the most peaceful gathering
that's such a crowd probably in the
history of our country
why August 28th any significance to that
particular day I don't think we had any
reason for selecting August 28 1963 but
I think it was Olga 28 1955 that a young
black man from Chicago by the name of
Emmett Till was lynched in mrs.
and I'm not sure if I had a day in mind
or not but between July 2nd in 1963 in
August 28th 1963 I think we felt that we
had enough time to organize and to
mobilize people to get there and it was
amazing to me we had that there was a
young lady who was a quarter native of
transportation by the name of Rochelle
Horowitz who were working with a fellow
Randolph and by arrested and you can
call her up at two o'clock in the
morning mr. Rochelle how many buses come
in from New York how many buses coming
from Philadelphia how many people don't
be on that train coming out of New
Orleans to Jackson Mississippi to
Birmingham to Atlanta and on to
Washington and she could tell us that so
it was organized it was disciplined next
calls from somebody who was there as we
look at more scenes this from the mall
here in Washington and the South Lawn of
the White House and there's the Lincoln
Memorial Jacksonville Florida you're
next hello I just wanted to remind mr.
Lewis a senator Lewis that there were a
lot of West Indians and Jamaicans that
participated in that March and I'd like
for that to be recognized because we
were there with Martin in San Augustine
we were there with him and on a March
where we were even significant we didn't
play in a part in the organization but
we were there as the ground troops
that's all I wanted to say well well
thank you very much and I agree
many citizens of all kind West Indies
made it to Washington from Florida from
New York especially from from Brooklyn
from Harlem from all over America and
thank you for all your wonderful working
and involvement Fort Polk Louisiana good
morning good morning
I'm calling from Fort Polk Louisiana
again good morning Republican joints
with John Lewis I'm calling because I'm
considered one of those vivacious baby
boomers early 30s strong real black
Mormon
and after I understand the march on
Washington but seems to be ridiculously
frustrated and I feel that although we
have obtained our freedom we still have
a long way to go blacks minorities the
women men were still being grossly
discriminated against not only in our
fair share of freedom in America but
overwhelmingly in employment and
promotions etc so the civil rights
movement it's fair dwelled in the late
60s but I feel that the amendment or our
Civil Rights Act does not protect and
protect them and minorities northa
blacks in the year of 2000 I feel this
because the racism and discrimination is
practice more than today than in 1963
well I'm not sure you said and I
appreciate you calling I'm not sure I
understood you didn't a Republican a
John Lewis I'm a Democrat I represent
Georgia the city of Atlanta and the
fifth District and I've been in Congress
17 years and I'm a pretty liberal
progressive Democrat by my record but
for those of you who think in essence
chain things have changed in 1963 we
still had those signs that said white
men colored men white women colored
women white waiting colored waiting
segregation and racism was open very
overt and if you don't believe anything
has changed come and walk in my shoes
and I'll show you we live in a different
world the spa's and stains of racism may
be still with us we're not there yet we
have not yet created the Beloved
Community or truly interracial democracy
but we own our way and we're not going
back we're not going to stand still
we're going to continue to make progress
and build a Beloved Community
bill of society that is at peace with
itself that is the direction of the
American Society of where we see
discrimination where we see racism but
we see people being discriminated
against because of that gender a sex
sexual orientation of whatever we have
to speak out against it we all have to
act we all can make a contribution we
don't need to wait for another
modifications Union to come along we all
have to be part of our own liberation 40
years later is that your message today
at this March my message today will be
that really that it's not enough for us
just to look back it is good to look
back to be renewed to be inspired to see
what another generation did but it's
also important for people to say what I
did it we can I do it we we all can do
something what has happened in America
today I think too many of us not just
young people all of us too quiet
you talked and wrote about this speech
earlier and we have an email from a
viewer who says mr. Lewis I know you are
peaceful and a diplomatic man so you
might be reluctant to explore the impact
of the Riverside Church speech on the
forces in the country which might have
contributed to dr. King's assassination
that is why it is minimized in the press
who wishes to stress the dreaminess of
the I have a dream speech important as
it was please comment the speech at the
Riverside Church was one of the most
moving statements of dr. King he talked
about violence in Vietnam and violence
here at home and he said I cannot
segregate my concern I cannot segregate
my morality he condemned the violence in
Vietnam and condemned the violence here
and he said in effect what President
Eisenhower said much earlier that when
we spend hundreds thousands and billions
of dollars on bombs missiles and gone
we're robbing our people and that must
be a better way
he was urging us to lay down the tools
and instrument of violence instead of
War no more another email from a viewer
in Kansas City with this comment it's
sad the civil rights movement has
devolved from a demand for equal rights
with which no decent person can argue
into a demand for extraordinary rights
like affirmative action and hate crime
legislation the present civil rights
movement is a corrupt abondon
of dr. King's dreamed that black
Americans would simply enjoy the same
rights and responsibilities as other
citizens the civil rights movement today
it is not just about civil rights it is
about the rights of all of our citizens
we still need that concept the policy of
affirmative action to include all of our
citizens that have been left at left
behind are not included whether they
been discriminated against because of
race or gender we have to affirm the
inclusion the involvement that
participation I'm not prepared to give
up on that idea of the Beloved Community
on open and just society hillside New
Jersey your next good morning good
morning I'm a black Republican woman I
was at the march on Washington it cost
$10 to go down on the bus those many
years ago I'd like to see more openness
and receptivity between parties
Republican and Democratic parties
specifically I'd like to see less
negative name-calling and more
involvement across the party lines I
want to praise you representative Louis
for your calmness for your sweetness if
I might say that for your tenacity your
enthusiasm and your work and I'd like to
call attention to the fact that down
through the years when women have played
a very important role they've held the
homes together while the men were out
there and many women were out there too
I'd like to see you take leadership and
in the area of harmony between
Republicans and Democrats especially
black Republicans I'm a lifetime member
of the NAACP and some years ago many
years ago my dad was the first black
person to be nominated to run for
Congress on the Republican ticket and
the 11th congressional district when he
would go to organizations especially in
a city they wouldn't even call his name
and it was because he was a Republican I
think that that kind of ridicule and
oestrogen
and shutting out can't help the site
colorful was your dad's name bill Stubbs
okay and I'd like to see I'd like to see
representative Lewis take some
leadership in trying to harmonize
between factions Thank You caller well
thank you very much for calling I tell
you some Sabine in Congress are co-chair
group here in Washington on the hill
called faith and politics with a
wonderful friend of mine we came to
Congress together
congressman Anil Holton from upstate New
York and he is the Republican and before
congressman JC Watts left to Congress we
worked very very well together we
introduced legislation together we
co-sponsored the African American Museum
because sponsor legislation to do
something about in in the disparity in
health of between the minority and
majority population I don't believe in
name-calling I believe in the philosophy
and the discipline of non-violence that
we have to work together and pull
together in a fine analyses as I've said
so many time in so many speeches maybe
just maybe we all came to this great
land in different ships but we all in
the same boat now Richmond Virginia for
Congressman John Lewis who at the age of
23 one of the speakers at the march on
Washington an event that will be
commemorated today and you'll be able to
watch it live here on c-span this
afternoon go ahead the Air Force pretty
wise man it's just amazing Here I am 44
years old I was three when Martin
fascinated and Kennedy wasn't president
and we used to ride with my dad when we
were in the truck and we used to see how
the country was and how the prejudice
was and sometimes we had to stay inside
the truck and you know I'm 44 and I have
six children alive very intelligent
children and the world today still so
racist against the people of minority
color I really can't believe that my
entire life was still fighting this
issue here it is we were released from
slavery in 1865 and we still fighting up
issues saddest racism is I'm John Lewis
well I appreciate you calling but I tell
you there are people working not just
government officials not just members of
Congress again as a congressperson or
senator rather a senator brownback from
the state of Kansas we've been champion
an effort to create a national
african-american Museum on the mall so
it is our feeling if we tell the story
the whole story of the history of
african-american in our country it would
help lead to reconciliation and to
healing we have to deal with the problem
of race but you shouldn't get lost in a
sea of despair you shouldn't become
bitter a hosta you know I went to jail
for a time I was beaten left unconscious
during the Freedom Rides in May of 1961
had a concussion at the bridge in Selma
on March 7 1965 and some of my
colleagues and friends in the Congress
meanwhile you're not bitter why you're
not hostile you don't have time to be
hostile you might have time to be bitter
we all have a role to play and we should
play it well do our part
not just to make America better but to
make our war to make our little planet a
better place for our born generations
here's a scene from the book the John
Lewis
authored walking with the wind just
moments before Alabama state troopers
attacked us on the bridge as he rode
from walking with a wind we'll get a
call from Montgomery Alabama good
morning Lois
and through your host in America I just
want to say that I'm really enjoying the
benefits of the things that you all did
in nineteen in the nineteen sixties so I
could have the freedom but I don't want
to talk about that I want to talk about
you just for a minute when I met you in
Montgomery Alabama at my church at First
Baptist you made me feel like I was the
only person in that church when you met
me you stopped and you talked and I tell
you I went home and it just made such an
impact on me and I just want to say that
uh as a young black man I respect you so
much I'm just so glad I cherished that
day that I met you and just to everybody
who's listening I know about the
political things that you do but I will
never ever in my life forget the way you
caused me to feel in that church when I
got off that pipe organ playing and I I
know y'all were tired
y'all had been up a long time Chris
Tucker was there I know that I know that
y'all were hungry and and I know a lot
of things but I'm just saying to you
personally that uh I really respect you
John Lewis and I just want you to know
that and I'm looking forward to the day
I can see you again thank you so much
well thank you so much for calling you
know in 1958 when I was 18 years old I
first met dr. King and Reverend Ralph
Abernathy at that church First Baptist
and I grew up on the 50 miles from
Montgomery so I have four members each
time I visit First Baptist in downtown
Montgomery and visit the city of
Montgomery thank you for calling this
viewer says it's an understatement that
leading the civil rights movement was
more than a full-time job how did you
and the other leaders of the movement
survive financially Steve I must say it
was not easy it was very difficult when
I became chair of the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee in June of 1963
I didn't have any major obligation I
only needed a place to sleep I had a
little apartment in Atlanta and I shared
it with a wonderful photographer by the
name of Danny line was from New York who
became this photographer for the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee and we
paid something like a $90 a month and
the organization helped us we were paid
something like $10.50 a week when their
taxes and everything was taken out and
people all across the country supported
us in terms of travel from one place to
another and when we got arrested and
went to jail there was some very good
people in Georgia in Alabama in
Mississippi in Tennessee and all across
the south and all across America who
raised money to have bail us out of jail
sure this photograph if we can go down
though I want to read what Denny Lyon
wrote to you from August 1963 Washington
DC on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial
for my friend John Lewis on that hot
summer day it was your speech that we
all waited to hear because you were more
you more than anyone else that day
speaking for all the young people of
SNCC known as snick or the south or the
high schools that created the movement
that caught the attention of the world
and inspired a generation of progress
and revolt I'm very grateful to Danny
line for writing that Danny made a great
contribution just using his camera and
it was very dangerous during those days
to have a camera to have a pencil and a
pen to be a member of the media because
people in the heart of the deep saw
didn't want the message to get out who
were all these people around you you
know many of those people were marshals
labor leaders union workers members that
were there in support and that several
members of Congress came to the March
and stood and took seats also on the
steps in front of the podium Orlando
Florida good morning good morning
gentlemen how you doing today good
morning I just want to mention to say
that I think the great thing
about the march on Washington was I
think the speech is still prevalent even
today when Martin Luther King was
talking about a dream I always see that
he had the vision of even how our
country should be years later and I
think about how you know the scripture
says without a vision the people perish
but like you were saying representative
it's always good to look back to see
where everything started but to pick up
and carry it on the way that I think dr.
team really envisioned even in today
after 9/11 when people come together and
as a country we need to come together
heal these wounds and I think that was
what was so prevalent about his speech
that it's even a today's speech that we
should adhere to and I just want to
thank you for being a part of it and you
know for laying the foundation another
caller from Roxboro North Carolina as we
look at more scenes from that date in
August 1963 good morning yes good
morning gentleman representative Lewis
of course I'm caught on the Republican
line and I mainly the reason I vote
Republican is mainly for their moral
issues I want to say that I appreciate
the work that you've done you know
before I was even born I was born in 67
and you know I changed me in a sense
that I took our country 100 and nearly
200 years to try to get things right for
all of our citizens and you know we look
at the Declaration of Independence where
it says we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal I cannot understand how our
forefathers could not upon our country's
freedom in the Revolutionary War didn't
make everybody free but you know besides
that I want to ask you what do you think
difference would have been if Martin
Luther King jr. had not tragically been
assassinated well thank you for calling
if one day the King jr. had not been
assassinated and President Kennedy and
Liv and Robert Kennedy and many others I
think we would be much further down that
road toward the building of a truly
interracial democracy dr. Cain had
emerged as a moral leader
perhaps more than any other American of
our time he had the power to bring more
people together to do good not just
african-americans but all people
dr. King was the undisputed undisputed
symbol of what was good and right about
America and he wanted to move America
much father and with the helpful
individuals like President Kennedy
another we would have been able to do
some Charleston South Carolina your next
good morning for Congressman John Lewis
of Georgia good morning representative
Lewis and to the host I just want to say
thank you and I commend you for all your
hard work and also for all our
forefathers fathers dr. Martin Luther
King and all the participants of the
March and for everything that that
you've done for us I just want to say
thank you and I just wish that I was
there to see all the great things that
had happened for the March because it
just looked like it was so peaceful and
so calm thanks for the comment last call
from Houston Texas good morning good
morning good morning mr. Lewis this is a
mr. Stroh CA calling I'd like to thank
you very much for what you've done what
you've stood for 40 years I'm proud to
be an African American and I just like
to say to you sir I don't think there is
a civil rights movement today it just
seems as though African American people
have just given up and there's no fight
in them it seemed as though all of our
so-called civil rights organizations or
speechless today they're not dealing
with the issues pertaining to the
injustice is done to African Americans
particularly African American men thanks
for the call we'll get a response thank
you very much for calling I said earlier
and I said to you you must never give up
a giving a give out you have to continue
to hang in there another generation of
young people and
one called us up and told us to go in
start sitting in get on a bus and going
to free to ride a start marching we were
deeply inspired by the words to monitor
King jr. deeply inspired by our history
books of what we knew about the
Constitution the Declaration of
Independence the Bill of Rights and we
had to act we had to move and I think
today in America not just
african-american but all of us all of us
are just a little too quiet we look too
complacent we have to get involved
we need to register and we need to go
out and vote you need to get involved in
political scene and civil organization
doing things because it's the right
thing to do you know you don't need to
wait on someone to come down from
Atlanta from New York to to help from
another part of the country you have to
do it in the south during the early 60s
indigenous leaders emerge young people
high school students college students
just got out there and got in the way
they start pushing and pulling and
that's what people must do today do
marches work today
I think marches still work dr. Caine
used to say that's nothing more powerful
than the margin feet of a determined
people Congressman John Lewis who's been
in the US House of Representatives since
1986 and will be at the Lincoln Memorial
later today to commemorate the 40th
anniversary you're always gracious with
your time here at c-span thanks for
being with us - thank you very much
really been a pleasure to be with you
and thank you for your good and great
work